We would have 52 and 817 1000ths inches squared. This is our correct answer.
Fantastic thinking if you got there. Now, I know we haven't seen a problem like
this one yet, or that involves the square of a quantity, so don't worry if you
struggled. Let's see how we can do it. Because the area varies directly, we want
to make sure that we list the first quantities that cross from one another. And
notice too that the area doesn't just vary directly with the radius, it varies
directly with the square of the radius. So we have to square the first radius.
And then, for our second area, it will also vary directly with the square of its
radius. Now that we have our proportion set up, let's fill in each of the
numbers in the appropriate place. This would be our first area and this would be
the radius that goes with it. So we want to put 28 and 278 1000ths here, and 3
here. Next we have the second radius which we know is 4 and 1 10th. So that will
go here, and then we'll use x for the area of 2. That's the area we're looking
for in our question. First I'm going to square each of these numbers to get this
fraction. Next we cross multiply to get this equation. And finally we divide
both sides by 9 to get our final answer.